all right we are in the post-election
paradigm of hatred mail I'll remind you
first what hatred mail is it's like
taking an apple pie filling it with
pages from the Old Testament topping it
with hollow points and serving it with a
side of homophobia Patriot Man written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America because freedom
all right this week's hatred mail a very
important analysis of the entire recount
scenario and election fraud allegations
in the November 8th presidential
election I think you'll quickly notice
I'm giving this Patriot mail a bit too
much credit let's take a listen to what
this hatred had to say take your BS and
stick it up you dot all the fraud was in
Clinton favor any recount will show
Clinton got a lot less I will lay you
odds anyone fraud on her count not Trump
you will see illegals for Clinton and
dead folk for Clinton she will not want
humiliating anymore go cry look at her
rallies compared to Trump's law how many
law you sell your meat knob head loll
you are showing yourself up Clinton
trying to say Russia hacked DNC she said
14 agencies said it then it's ten
thousand percent it was a American
blamed Russia it's not because it's a
lie idiot super cogent and well reasoned
in all seriousness when this hatred
wrote this I genuinely wondered whether
they had maybe experienced a psychotic
break which wouldn't be funny at all or
maybe they were on some kind of
hallucinogenics at the time that they
wrote in I can't really think of another
explanation for receiving something like
this and I know that a lot of people see
these and they wonder are these people
even American because their lack of a
grasp on the English language seems so
significant I don't think that that's
actually let me put it a different way I
think that we shouldn't laugh at the
reality that we have a real serious
education problem here in the United
States and that these are people who
presumably at least had available
schools in the United States and we
can't say for sure whether they went or
not and this is the way that they end up
writing presumably as adults I don't
think that's something to laugh at at
all I think that's actually a really
serious indictment of much of what we
have as a problem in this country last
thing you can always turn hatred mail
into something positive by using the
coupon code Patriot 40 at david
pakman.com slash membership for a big
league discount off of membership prices